foreign
welcome to another installment of Harry
Potter Theory
today we're going to be discussing
spells in fact we're going to be
discussing every known spell in The
Wizarding World this one was a bit of a
doozy to make but I learned a ton of new
info in the research process so I hope
you can appreciate my efforts and learn
a little bit more about the rich library
of spells in The Wizarding World
before we get started however I should
mention that the Spells compiled on this
list come from all manners of Harry
Potter resources including books films
games spin-offs Etc I also want to
briefly introduce you to the types of
spells
from the 309 odd spells in the Harry
Potter Universe most can be categorized
within one of the following spell types
starting from the top the term spell is
merely a very very broad term for any
piece of magic it refers to a controlled
manifestation of magic that affects the
world in a supernatural way it can range
immensely and includes all matters of
magic from stunning someone to
levitating an object
spells are generally cast by witch or
Wizard and are usually produced via some
form of incantation because of the
generic nature of the word spell it
could be the appropriate term to use in
almost every Circumstance the spell is a
non-specific umbrella term that would
cover other things like charms hexes
curses and enchantments
though using the term spell would never
be incorrect some situations might
warrant a more specific term as spell is
so broad a charm is an expression that
refers to spells which adds certain
properties to objects or individuals
charms should not be confused with
transfigurations as Transfiguration
refers to a spell that changes what the
object is rather than just changing
properties of the object there are
countless charms in Harry Potter that
cover an extensive number of outcomes
curses are actually a type of charm but
a dark one the expression curse is used
exclusively for the charms that aren't
darkest in nature the worst kinds of
dark magic think the three unforgivable
curses
technically a curse is defined as any
spell that affects an object in a
negative manner typically associated
with some sort of discomfort this
definition applies to regular dark
charms and curses but typically a curse
is more severe hexes and jinxers are
also considered to be dark charms but
are less severe than curses in order of
severity it goes curse hex Jinx jinxers
are mainly irritating amusing and
basically harmless hexes on the other
hand are a slightly more malicious form
of jinxes but not so bad that they
weren't curse status with those
definitions out of the way let's dive in
Alberto this spell is used to open or
unlock doors windows and other objects
that are magically sealed or closed when
cast it causes the targeted object to
release its lock or barrier granting
access
accio also known as the summoning charm
Akio is used to attract or cool objects
towards the Caster it allows the user to
bring an object to them even if it is
located far away
aguamenti this Bell creates a jet of
clean drinkable water from the Caster's
wand it is commonly used to provide
water in situations where it's needed
such as quenching thirst or
extinguishing small fires a latte
ascendere this is a spell that causes
the target to be lifted High into the
air it is often used in duels to disable
opponents by throwing them into the air
making them vulnerable or disorienting
them Albus Dumbledore's forceful spell
little is known about this offensive
spell but we do know that it was cast by
Dumbledore and that Voldemort to conjure
a silver Shield to deflect it this
happened inside the ministry of magic
alohomora also known as the unlocking
charm alohomora is used to unlock and
open doors locks or latches
alohomora is commonly used by witches
and wizards to gain entry into sealed or
locked places
a motto Animo and Amato and omegas this
spell is used as part of the process of
becoming an animagus the Spell's name
which is also the incantation has to be
recited at Sunrise and Sundown every day
before the consumption of an animagus
potion
anapnio anapnio is a healing spell used
to clear the airway of a person who's
choking when cast it causes the
obstructed person to breathe normally
again it's a life-saving spell commonly
used by healers or individuals trained
in first aid antioculation this dark
charm causes the target to grow antlers
anti-cheating spell this charm is used
during examinations to prevent cheating
it creates protective enchantments
around the exam area making it difficult
for students to cheat using magical
means such as charms or spell casting
typically these spells were used on
quills and parchment
anti-disapparition jinx this spell is
used to prevent others from
disapparating which is a form of magical
teleportation the anti-disapparition
Jinx creates a barrier or enchantment
that restricts the ability to disappear
ensuring that individuals cannot vanish
or Escape through magical teleportation
anti-intruder jinx this Bell creates
defensive or deterrent enchantments that
make it more difficult or dangerous for
unauthorized individuals to enter a
certain area it was used in 1996 to
protect Hogwarts Antonin dolohov's curse
this curse refers to a purple curse that
was used by the Death Eater Antonin
dalahov not much is known about this
curse but given dalhof's reputation as a
dangerous wizard it is likely a dark
curse with harmful effects Apparition
this is a revealing spell used to render
invisible or hidden writings such as
invisible ink or Enchanted texts visible
again
when this charm is cast it unveils the
hidden writing apare vestigium this Bell
is used to reveal traces of Magic
including Footprints and track marks
it's used by newt's Commander
Apparition Apparition is a magical form
of transportation that allows witches
and wizards to instantaneously teleport
from one location to another it requires
skill and a license to perform legally
Apparition involves the wizard or witch
concentrating on their intended
destination and then disappearing from
their current location only to reappear
the desired place it can be highly
dangerous Aqua iraqto this spell is used
to produce a gentle stream of controlled
water from the cast as wand it is often
used to extinguish fires or water plants
arania exumai this spell is used to
repel or Blast Away spiders when the
spell is cast it creates a force that
repels or sends spiders flying away from
the caster
Resto momentum
this spell is used to slow down or stop
the movement of an object or person it
can be cast to reduce the speed of a
falling object or to Halt the movement
of a fast-moving person or animal
providing a short moment of respite
arrow shooting spell this Bell fires
arrows from the Caster's wand
ascendio this spell is used to propel
the Caster High into the air it is often
used when a quick elevation or Escape is
desired Avada cadaver this is one of the
three unforgivable curses and one of the
most well-known spells it is a killing
curse that causes instant death to the
Target when cast a vivid flash of green
light is emitted from the cast as wand
and the victim immediately Falls
lifeless RV Force this Transfiguration
spell turns objects into Birds it
requires a high level of skill and
knowledge in Transfiguration Arvin
Sequim this Bell is used to turn an
object into a tracking device it's used
by Newt scamander to track the origins
of a Feather Arvest this Bell is used to
conjure a flock of birds from the cast
as wand when cast a stream of birds
typically canaries are produced and sent
flying out into the surroundings
babbling curse this curse causes the
target to babble incoherently making it
difficult for them to communicate
effectively
the spell renders the victim's speech
nonsensical causing them to babble or
speak gibberish badgering a form of
transfiguration that turns thing into
badges
bat bogey hex this hex targets the
victim's nose and turns their bogeys
into large flying bats the hex is
commonly used by the Weasley twins Fred
and George as a prank or form of mild
punishment bourbilius this Bell produces
a bolt of white light from the tip of
the wand it's likely the incantation for
white Sparks
bedazzling hex little is known about
this spell as it is only vaguely
mentioned however it's likely that some
sort of hacks used to disguise things
Bewitched snowballs this spell is used
by Fred and George Weasley it causes
snowballs to Pelt themselves at the
Target
Bluebell flames
this Bell is used to produce
blue-colored Flames from the Caster's
wand that can be held in a jar these
Flames are known for their cooler than
normal temperature and safe nature
blue Sparks this spell produces blue
Sparks or fireworks from the Caster's
wand it is often used for decorative
purposes or as a show of magic
bombarder this is an explosive offensive
spell that causes a targeted object to
burst or be blown apart it is commonly
used to blast through obstacles or break
down barriers the strength and
destructiveness of the explosion can
vary depending on the Caster's skill and
intention
bombardo Maxima this is an advanced
version of the Bombardier spell similar
to bombarda it produces a powerful
explosion but the impact is
significantly larger and more
destructive this spell is typically used
to collapse structures or cause
widespread damage
brachium amendo
this Bell is likely used to mend or heal
a broken arm as brachium refers to the
arm it was used unsuccessfully by
gildora Lockhart one Harry
bravery charm this charm increases The
Bravery of someone
Bridge Conjuring spell this spell is
used to create a bridge where there may
not be one by casting the spell a wizard
can conjure a sturdy and functional
bridge to cross over gaps or water
bodies it's used in the tale of the
three brothers
broom jinx this Jinx is used to hinder
or disrupt the flying ability of a
broomstick when cast it can cause the
broomstick to become unsteady lose
control or even halt in mid-air it's
often used to sabotage a person's
Transportation on a broomstick bubble
head charm this spell encases the head
of the Caster or another person in a
bubble of breathable air it allows the
person inside the bubble to breathe
underwater or in a contaminated or
airless environment for a limited time
bubble spell this spell is used to
create non-bursting Bubbles from the tip
of a wand possibly for entertainment or
other purposes
calvorio this Bell is used to remove a
victim's hair
this spell causes the victim to burst
uncontrollably into song
capacious extremists this Bell is used
to enlarge the inside of an object
creating more space or capacity
it allows the Caster to store larger
items or fit more items into a specific
container without altering the external
appearance of the object Carpe retract
them this spell produces a magical
retractable rope from the Caster's wand
the robe can be directed to latch onto
objects or people and pull them towards
the Caster or move them in a desired
Direction
cascading Jinks while it's not well
documented this Jinx likely creates some
sort of a cascading effect
possibly causing objects or effects to
multiply or spread rapidly catawling
charm this is a protective charm that
produces a loud high-pitched shriek when
triggered by an unauthorized personal
creature entering a specific area
it is often used to alert the Caster or
others of intruders or to provide a
warning signal
cauldron to Sev a form of
transfiguration that turns cauldrons
into sevs
cauldron to Badger a form of
transfiguration that turns cauldrons
into a badger a form of badgering
this is a defensive spell used to
protect an area from Intruders it
creates a magical barrier or Shield that
prevents enemies or unwanted individuals
from seeing or entering the protected
area
this spell causes plants within a
greenhouse to grow at an accelerated
rate
cheering charm this spell is used to
brighten someone's Spirits or alleviate
sadness it often causes them to break
out into an uncontrollable laughing fit
circum rotor this charm is used to
rotate objects it was created by Lita
Lestrange the system aperio this Bell
which means open the chest in Latin is a
spell used to open or unlock a chest box
or container galaportis this spell is
used to magically lock a door and
prevent it from being opened when the
spell is cast the targeted door becomes
sealed shut and cannot be opened by
regular means this is the counter charm
to the unlocking spell alohomora kuloshu
this hex sticks the target's shoes to
the ground
golovaria this spell is used to change
the color of an object combat bolt this
offensive spell projects a bolt of
energy
confringo this powerful blasting curse
causes the target to explode or burst
into flames upon impact
it is a highly destructive spell and is
often employed in duels or combat
situations
the explosion caused by confringo can
inflict significant damage to both
objects and living beings
confundo this Bell also known as the
confundus charm is a spell used to
confuse or bewilder the target
when cast it causes a mild state of
confusion or disorientation making the
affected person more susceptible to
suggestion or prone to making mistakes
conjunctivitis curse this curse affects
the target's eyes causing extreme
irritation and temporary Vision
impairment
this curse can cause the eyes to swell
Redden and produce excess tears
rendering the target unable to see
clearly dragons are particularly
susceptible to this curse
cornflake skin spell this spell causes
the victim's skin to appear as though it
is coated in corn flakes
cracker jinx this Jinx is used to
conjure exploding wizard crackers
cribbing spell this spell assists the
Caster in cheating on written papers
tests and exams kryness Muto this Bell
is a form of transfiguration and is used
to change the color and style of one's
hair
crucio the cruciatus curse another one
of the unforgivable curses is known for
causing intense excruciating pain upon
the target
the curse causes unbearable suffering
and often results in the Target
convulsing uncontrollably it is an
unforgivable act to use this curse on
another human being defodio this spell
is used to carve or dig into a surface
such as stone or Earth
when cast it creates a cutting or
drilling effect allowing the Caster to
excavate or create openings in solid
materials deleterious this charm is used
to erase or banish the effects of a
prior spell particularly the lingering
traces or remnants of magical
manifestations
densorgio this hex affects the target's
teeth causing them to enlarge rapidly
when cast it enlarges the teeth to an
exaggerated size potentially causing
discomfort or impairing the target's
ability to speak or eat de Primo this
powerful spell generates a concentrated
blast used to blow holes in the ground
de pulso this repelling charm is used to
forcibly shove or push away a Target
when cast it sends a targeted object
flying backward similar to a forceful
push or shove this spell can be used to
repel attackers or push obstacles out of
the way
descendo this spell is used to lower or
move an object in the downward Direction
when cast it causes the directed object
to descend either falling to the ground
or moving down to a lower position
desk into Pig this spell a form of
transfiguration turns desks into pigs
deterioration hex this offensive hex
impairs foes and reduces their stamina
defendo this cutting spell is used to
precisely sever or divide objects when
cast it is capable of cleanly cutting
through various materials such as fabric
ropes or even living matter
diminuendo this charm causes the target
to shrink it's used by Nigel walpert in
a Dumbledore's army meeting
descendium this spell is used to open
passages in 1993 it used to open the
statue of gun Hilda of course more
disintegration spell
this dark offensive charm causes the
target to burst into small pieces and
disintegrate this may have been used by
Molly Weasley on Bellatrix Lestrange
disillusionment charm this charm is used
to make the target blend in with their
surroundings rendering them partially
invisible or camouflaged similar to a
chameleon
draconophores this spell transforms an
object typically a statue or a small
figurine into a dragon
when cast it enchants the object causing
it to come to life as a small temporary
dragon that can fly and move around
drought charm this spell is used to
remove or repel excessive amounts of
water causing these sources of water to
dry up
ducklafores this spell is used to
transform a Target most commonly a small
object into a duck when cast it brings
the object to Life as a living duck
Duro this spell is used to petrify or
Harden objects turning them to Stone
ears to kumquat's spell this spell
transforms the victim's ears into
kumquats ear shriveling curse this curse
is used to cause severe harm or
defamation to the target's ears forcing
them to shrivel up e bubblio this
offensive spell is used to conjure a
bubble or spherical barrier of air
around the target containing them inside
and gorgio this Bell is used to enlarge
or expand the size of the target when
cast it causes the target to grow larger
whether it's an object a creature or a
body part the counter charm is the
shrinking charm and gorgio scullus this
offensive dark charm is used to cause
the victim's skull to swell
disproportionately
enter morphis this Jinx is used to
transform the target into an insect for
a short time
entrail expelling curse this horrible
dark curse is used to forcibly remove a
person's entrails in my opinion this is
one of the worst curses out there
superseding even the three unforgivable
curses episcopy this healing spell is
used to mend minor injuries such as
broken bones or lacerations it is not as
powerful or comprehensive as more
advanced healing magic used for more
serious injuries
epoximize this spell adheres one object
to another as if they are glued together
erecto this Bell is used to erect or
raise objects and is particularly used
for constructing structures or building
Frameworks evanesque evanesco this spell
also known as The Vanishing spell is
used to make objects vanish or disappear
when cast it causes the targeted object
to evaporate or dissolve into
nothingness making it effectively vanish
from sight iverte Statum this spell is
used to knock an opponent off their feet
it creates a forceful blast or jolt that
repels the Target and sends implying or
stumbling backward
expecto patronum this powerful spell is
used to conjure a powerful protective
charm in the form of a guardian figure
known as a Patronus
the Patronus typically takes the shape
of an animal that represents positive
protective qualities and is capable of
fending off dark creatures such as
dementas or leather faults there are two
forms of the spell corporeal and
non-corporeal
Expelliarmus this Bell which seems to be
about the only one Harry knows is used
to disarm the opponent by forcibly
removing the wand or weapon from their
grasp it creates a forceful wave of
energy that knocks the weapon away from
them
expulso this curse creates a powerful
explosion capable of destroying objects
or structures
it's Unique in that it uses pressure
instead of heat
extinguishing spell this spell is used
to put out fires or extinguish flames
false memory charm this charm is used to
modify or erase a person's memories when
cast it can either completely remove
specific memories or alter them leading
the target to remember false events or
information
a Featherlite charm this Bell is used to
make an object lighter in weight as
light as a feather
ferret to human this form of
transfiguration transforms a ferret into
a human though it's likely that it only
works on reversing humans that had
already been turned into ferrets varula
this spell is used to conjure bandages
or splints that can be used to
immobilize or stabilize injured body
parts
when cast it creates bandages that wrap
around the injured area providing
support and aiding in the healing
process
viento duri this defensive charm is used
to strengthen Shield spells fidelius
charm another very famous spell from the
series the fidelius charm is used to
conceal a secret or piece of information
within the soul of an individual known
as The Secret Keeper when the charm is
cast The Secret becomes hidden and
cannot be revealed unless the Secret
Keeper chooses to disclose it
fiend fire this incredibly dangerous and
uncontrollable dark curse manifests as a
raging Inferno it takes the form of
beasts and creatures that burn and
destroy everything in their path
because fiend fire is so extremely
difficult to control it can cause
widespread devastation
fenestra this charm is used to shatter
glass finite in cantatum this spell is
used to negate or stop the effects of
ongoing spells within the vicinity of
the caster
finger removing jinx this is a spell
that as the name suggests causes
someone's fingers to be removed
Firestorm this powerful offensive spell
produces a ring of fire from the wand
that surrounds the Caster Dumbledore
notably uses this on the in fairy in the
cave flagrante curse this curse causes
objects to burn on contact
this Bell allows the Caster to draw or
write to the wand by leaving a trail of
fire in mid-air it can be used to create
fiery patterns draw attention or leave
messages behind it's notably used by Tom
Riddle
flame freezing charm this charm causes
the target to be tickled by Flames
instead of being burned
flask Conjuring spell this charm
conjures a flask out of thin air which
can be used to hold liquids or potions
flintophos this Bell is used to
transform small objects into match boxes
flippendo this Bell also known as the
knockback Jinx releases a forceful blast
of air similar to a concussive blast it
can be used to push back or knock over
objects as well as stun or temporarily
incapacitate opponents flippendo Duo
this is a more advanced version of the
flippendo spell that produces a more
powerful blast flipender Maxima this is
the most powerful variation of the
flopendo spell releasing an even more
powerful blast
flippendotria another variation of
flippendo this spell which resembles a
mini tornado is said to be more powerful
than flippendo Duo but less powerful
than flippendo Maxima
flying charm this spell enchants objects
usually brooms and flying carpets and
allows them to fly fracto strata this
zap type spell is used to break weak
objects into pieces
few Moss this defensive spell creates a
cloud or veil of Thick Smoke similar to
a smoke screen it can be used to provide
cover or concealment making it harder
for enemies to see or Target the caster
Viewmaster Duo this more advanced
version of the few more spell creates a
larger and denser cloud of smoke
providing even greater cover or
obscuring the visibility of a larger
area for nun Killers this Jinx causes
the target to break out in painful boils
or blisters all over their body it
inflicts discomfort and can be used as a
means of temporary immobilization or
distraction
the first spell this charm is used to
magically transform the texture of an
object or creature's surface into fur
geminio this Bell is used to create a
duplicate or copy of an object when used
to duplicate objects indefinitely it's
referred to as the germanio curse
glaciers this offensive spell is used to
produce a blast of freezing cold air
that freezes the target glacias Duo a
more advanced version of the Iglesias
spell glacier's Duo creates an even more
intense burst of cold air that results
in a stronger freezing effect
glacias Tria this spell is the most
powerful of the glacias spell family
producing the coldest blast of air with
the longest lasting effect
glisio this spell transforms a flight of
stairs into a smooth slide-like surface
allowing individuals to Glide smoothly
down them
green Sparks this Basic Spell produces a
burst of green luminescent Sparks it is
often used for decorative or signaling
purposes
gripping charm this charm enhances the
grip or sticking ability of an object it
usually used on quaffles to help Chasers
carry them in quidditch
guy trash Conjuring spell this dark
spell conjures luminous green guy
trashes from the wand a large dog-like
spirit with a forked tail hair
thickening charm this charm is used to
enhance the thickness and volume of the
target's hair harmonia nectaray passes
this Bell is used to repair a Vanishing
cabinet
herbivores this Bell causes flowers to
sprout from the target
herbivicus this Bell is used to Aid in
the growth and nourishment of plants
when cast on a plant it rapidly
increases the speed at which it grows
Hermione Granger's jinx this Jinx causes
a traitor to break out in boils spelling
sneak on their forehead
homing spell this offensive spell
produces a floating ball of light that
follows the target
homonym revelio this spell is used to
reveal the presence of human beings in
the vicinity of the caster homunculus
charm this charm tracks the movements of
human beings and cannot be fooled by
methods of concealment
it was this charm that allowed the
Marauders map to function so effectively
homorphous charm this Bell is used to
transform werewolves back into their
human forms horn tongue hex this hex
caused the victim to sprout a large
curling ram-like horn from their tongue
Horton Keith breaking charm this charm
used on brooms allows them to more
effectively slow down and come to a halt
it is primarily used in quidditch
matches where precision and control are
necessary for success
horcrux making spell perhaps the worst
and darkest spell of them all this
forbidden curse is used to create
horcruxes objects in which a witch or
wizard imparts a piece of their soul
this spell requires a great deal of dark
magic and sacrifice marking the Creator
as a truly ruthless and powerful wizard
hot air charm this charm is used to
create a stream of hot gusting air
our reversal charm this charm is used to
manipulate time allowing the Caster to
reverse small amounts of it up to 5
hours
hover charm this spell is used to
levitate objects into the air and make
them float it's a lesser form of the
levitation charm
hurling hex this Jinx causes brooms to
vibrate violently in the air and to
knock their Rider off
this happens to Harry during a quidditch
match
illegibilis this Bell makes the
handwriting illegible or difficult to
read when cast on a piece of writing it
can obscure or garble the words making
them indecipherable
immobulus this battle is used to freeze
or immobilize the target when cast on a
person or object it can render them
completely motionless making them easier
to control or handle
impedimenta this Jinx is used to slow
down or obstruct movement
imperio another of the unforgivable
curses the imperious curse grants the
Caster complete control over the
victim's actions allowing them to
manipulate and command the victim at
will it's a powerful form of Mind
Control
imperturbable charm this charm creates
an invisible barrier that muffles sounds
and causes objects to bounce off of it
impervious this charm allows an object
to repel water and mist
in animators conjuris this Bell conjures
an inanimate object of some kind
incarcerous this offensive spell is used
to bind or restrain a target with thick
ropes or cords when cast it conjures
ropes would shoot out from the cast as
wand and wrap around the target
immobilizing them
incendio this is a basic Fire Starting
spell when cast ignites flames and can
be used to set objects or areas on fire
incendio Duo a stronger version of
incendio incendio Trio an even stronger
version of incendio
inflators this Bell inflates a Target
filling it with air we see the spell in
action with Harry's Aunt Marge Infamous
this Bell is used to complete one's
folio bruty instant scalping hex this
hex causes the victim's hair to
instantly fall out causing a complete
removal of all hair on their head
Intruder charm this protective spell is
used to detect and warn of the presence
of intruders when cast in an area or
object it can alert the Caster or
security system to the presence of
unauthorized individuals jelly legs
curse this curse also known as the
locomotor whibley spell is used to make
the target's legs turn to jelly causing
them to lose control and have difficulty
walking
Jelly Brain jinx this Jinx affects the
victim's mental functioning causing
their thoughts in cognitive processes to
become muddled and Confused like a brain
made of jelly when cast it can lead to
difficulty in thinking clearly and to
making rational decisions jelly fingers
curse this curse affects the dexterity
and control of the target's fingers when
cast it makes the victim's fingers
become jellied or slippery making it
difficult for them to accurately grasp
or hold onto objects
knee reversal hex this hex puts people's
knees on backward
the carnum inflamari this charm is used
to ignite cloaks Lang lock this Jinx
created by Severus Snape causes the
target's tongue to stick to the roof of
their mouth preventing them from
speaking
lap Force this Bell is used to transform
an object into a rabbit
leak jinx this Jinx causes leaks to
sprout from the victim's ears
legilimency this powerful spell gives
the Caster the ability to read and delve
into another person's mind allowing them
to enter and explore their thoughts
memories and emotions
Leather Corpus this curse created by
Severus Snape causes the target to be
suspended upside down in mid-air by
their ankle when cast the victim is
lifted off the ground and dangles
helplessly with their body completely
inverted Libera Corpus this is the
counter spell to Levy Corpus when cast
it releases a person from the levitation
caused by the Leather Corpus spell
bringing them back to a normal standing
position
locomotor this is a general movement
spell used to levitate an object or
Target a few inches off of the ground
when cast it causes the targeted object
to move or be directed as per the cast
as well
locomotor mortis this Bell also known as
the leg Locker curse is a jinx that
locks the victim's legs together
immobilizing them
when cast it can render a person
temporarily unable to move their legs
lumos this charm is used to produce
light from the tip of the Caster's wand
when cast it creates a steady beam of
light allowing the Caster to navigate in
darkness or illuminate their
surroundings
lumos Duo this variant of lumos creates
a more focused beam of light
luma's Maxima the most powerful spell in
the lumos family lumos maxima creates an
intensified burst of light Illuminating
a larger area than the standard lumos
spell lumos solemn this version of lumos
creates a focused beam of bright
sunlight like light it is primarily used
to repel and deter creatures sensitive
to sunlight such as vampires or certain
dark creatures magicus extremos this
charm temporarily increases a Caster's
spell power
metaphors this Jinx encases the victim's
head in a pumpkin
meteorologist recanto this spell is used
to Cease the effects of a previously
cast weather modifying spell which
Alters or controls the weather in some
way
when cast it Returns the weather
conditions to their normal state
mimblewimble this curse is used to
prevent someone from speaking when cast
it causes the person's tongue to knot up
making it difficult for them to speak
it's useful in tools as it forces them
to use non-verbal Magic
Ministry of magic fog this ministry of
magic patented charm conceals certain
areas from muggle View
mobiliabus this charm is used to
levitate wooden objects a few inches off
the ground and move them in any given
Direction
mobilic Corpus this Bell is used to
levitate and move a body typically an
unconscious or immobilized person
maliare this charm produces an invisible
cushion over the target it is used
primarily in the manufacturing of
Broomsticks
this spell conjures the dark mark a
Sinister skull and serpent symbol
associated with Lord Voldemort and his
Death Eaters when cast it creates a
floating green Mark in the sky serving
as an ominous dark sign indicating their
presence mucus ad nauseum this curse
gives the victim a cold along with the
runny nose and fits of sneezing
mafliato this charm created by Severus
Snape prevents people from hearing
conversations by filling their ears with
an unidentifiable buzzing sound
multi-core Force this charm is used to
change the color and style of one's
clothing
mutatio scullus this dark charm is used
to mutate a victim's head causing them
to grow extra heads it was reportedly
used by ancient Egyptian Wizards Knox
this Bell is used to extinguish or turn
off the light emitted from the cast as
wand when cast it ends the lumo spell
and causes the light to disappear
returning the wand to its normal State
nebulous this Bell creates fog from the
tip of the wand it can be seen in
Fantastic Beasts when Dumbledore meets
newt's Commander
Oculus repero this spell is used to
repair broken or damaged eyeglasses when
cast it restores the glasses to their
original state fixing any cracks breaks
or other damage
obliteration charm this spell is used to
erase or remove traces of footprints or
tracks obliviate also known as the
memory charm this powerful spell is used
to erase the memories of another person
when cast it can selectively remove
specific memories or wipe out an
individual's entire memory of a
particular event or time period it's
often used in conjunction with the false
memory charm obscuro this spell creates
a blindfold like layer over the eyes of
the target
oppugno this Jinx causes objects to
attack or assault a specific Target when
cast it directs the objects to launch an
offensive against the designated
recipient of the spell
orbis this spell is used to suck the
target into the ground often burrowing
up dirt in the process
or kidius this charm conches a
blossoming bouquet of flowers oscausi
this horrifying dark charm seals
someone's mouth shut and makes it look
as though no mouth was ever there
pack this extremely Basic Spell is used
to pack luggage
pain extraction spell
this Bell is used to remove or extract
physical pain from a person's body when
cast it can alleviate or eliminate their
suffering
Papyrus rapero A variation of repero
this Bell is used to mend torn pieces of
paper
patented Daydream charm this charm
transports the user to a highly
realistic and Vivid Daydream of their
choosing allowing them to temporarily
escape from reality
typically last 30 minutes
parties temporus this Bell is used to
create a gap in something a good example
of it being used is when Dumbledore
casts his ring of fire and needs to
create a gap for him and Harry to pass
through
pepper breath this Bell gives the victim
fiery hot peppery breath curriculum this
Basic Spell creates red Sparks of light
it is mainly used as a distress signal
or to indicate Danger
permanent sticking charm this charm is
used to affix or permanently attach an
object to another surface or object
pesky pixie pestinomi this Bell famously
and unsuccessfully utilized by gilderoy
Lockhart is meant to remove and control
Cornish Pixies it's unknown whether the
spell actually works or not petrificus
totalus this spell also known as the
full body bind curse is used to
immobilize and paralyze a person
completely when cast it leaves the
target unable to move or defend
themselves essentially freezing them in
place after being frozen usually the
victim will fall to the ground
locomotor this powerful incantation is
used to animate or bring to life
inanimate objects such as suits of armor
or statues when cast it empowers the
objects to move and follow the Caster's
commands pisky Force this charm is used
to transfigure or transform an object
into a fish
placement charm this charm is used to
magically place an object in or on a
specific location
Point me also known as the four point
spell this charmness used to help the
Caster find their way or locate the
direction of North when cast it causes
the cast as wand to act as a compass
pointing North importers this charm is
used to enchant an object as a portkey
when cast It imbues The Chosen object
with the ability to transport anyone who
touches it to a predetermined
destination allowing for long-distance
magical travel
Brio incantato this spell reveals spells
previously cast from a wand when cast on
a wand these spells manifest as ghostly
Echoes or images of the incantations or
effects this spell can manifest in the
form of the reverse spell effect
otherwise known as priori in cantatum
when ones with the same core try to do
battle protein charm this charm causes
copies of an object to be remotely
affected by changes made to the original
this Jinx transforms objects and people
into chickens
brataygo also known as The Shield charm
this defensive spell is used to create
an invisible shield or barrier that
blocks or deflects various types of
magical attacks when cast it can protect
the Caster from curses hexes jinxers and
other offensive spells
protego diabolica the most powerful form
of protego and potentially the most
powerful spell in The Wizarding World
protego diabolica conjures a protective
ring of black fire around the Caster
that destroys everyone but their enemies
the Caster is also able to shoot 10
trills of flame that incinerate anything
they touch protego or abilis another
member of the protego family protego
horabilis is a powerful Shield charm
devised for use against dark magic
Maxima this spell is a more advanced
version of the basic protego charm it
creates a more powerful and durable
Shield capable of withstanding stronger
magical assaults and providing enhanced
protection to the caster and their
allies
protego totalum another protego this
version of potato creates a protective
barrier around an area providing a
shield that defends against magical
attacks it's also used to repel
Intruders purple firecrackers this spell
produces purple firecrackers that shoot
out the tip of a wand
pus squirting spell this dark charm
causes yellowish goo to squirt from the
victim's nose and quietus this charm is
used to lower or silence the volume of
sound when cast it can quieten or reduce
the intensity of loud noises making them
less disruptive or noticeable redactum
scullus this Bell shrinks the head of a
Target it's the counter spell for
incorgioskellus which increases the size
of the skull
reducio this charm is used to shrink the
size of an object when cast it causes
the target object to decrease in size
making it smaller and more compact
reducto this powerful offensive spell is
used to blast or break apart objects
when cast it releases a strong burst of
force capable of causing explosions
demolishing barriers or shattering solid
structures
refilling charm this charm is used to
refill or replenish a container's
contents magically
repair force this Bell reverts minor
magically induced ailments such as
paralysis and poisoning reverte this
Bell returns objects to their original
positions or States
relatio this charm is used to force a
Target to release its grip on whatever
it's holding renovate the counter charm
to the stunning spell stupefy this charm
is used to awaken or revive an
unconscious person
repairage this Bell is used to reverse
incomplete Transformations specifically
those meddling with Transfiguration
repero this charm is used to repair
objects that have been broken or damaged
this charm is used to repel or keep away
Muggles from entering a specific area
when cast it creates a barrier or Ward
that prevents Muggles from perceiving or
entering the protected Zone by causing
them to forget what they were doing
repello anemicum a spell used to protect
Hogwarts Castle this protective charm
creates a barrier that disintegrates
anyone who tries to pass through it
revelio this charm is used to reveal
concealed or hidden objects Richter
sempra this charm is used to inflict a
tickling sensation or laughter on the
target when cast it causes the affected
person to experience strong involuntary
laughter and a tickling sensation
ridiculous this Bell is used to
transform boggetts shape-shifting
creatures that take on the form of a
person's greatest fear into something
comical or amusing when cast it forces
the bogot to assume a ridiculous or
funny form which helps to weaken its
power Rose growth this Bell causes roses
to grow at an unusually fast pace
robot spell this charm is used to make
boats row themselves it can be seen in
use on the boats that transport First
Years from hogsmeade to The Boathouse
salvio hexia this protective charm is
used to create a shield or barrier
around an area or defend it against
Texas or jinxers the Sardine hex this
hex causes the victim to sneeze out
sardines
The Source making spell this charm
Contours a creamy Source from the tip of
the wand
scourgeify this spell is used to clean
and remove dirt or filth from objects or
surfaces the sealant charm this rather
Basic Spell is used to seal envelopes
sea urchin jinx this Bell turns a victim
into a sea urchin sectum sempra this
dark offensive spell created by Severus
Snape causes deep slashing cuts to
appear on the target as if they had been
slashed by a sword it typically results
in severe wounds and bleeding the
counter curse is vulnera senentor
Shield penetration spell this powerful
offensive spell is used to destroy all
magical enchantments and shields such as
variations of protego it's used by
Voldemort to take down the defenses
protecting Hogwarts
shooting spell this rather generic spell
shoots something it was used by Harry
and Ron on their horcrux hunt to try and
catch a rabbit
smashing spell also rather generic in
nature this Bell produces an explosion
and smashes things serpent sorcer this
Conjuring spell is used to summon a
snake which emerges from the cast as
wand
silencio this charm is used to silence
or mute sounds when cast it prevents the
target from making any noise rendering
them unable to speak or produce sound
Scourge this spell is used to remove or
dissolve ectoplasm or the residue left
behind by ghosts or other spectral
entities
slippery jinx this Jinx makes an object
or Surface slippery or greasy
a slugulous erecto also known as the
slug vomiting charm this curse forces
the victim to burp up slugs
Sonora's charm this charm is used to
emit a magnified Roar from the tip of
the wand that disrupts all noises in its
path
sonores this spell is used to amplify
sounds or voices when cast it creates a
powerful booming voice that can be heard
over long distances
specialis revelio this charm is used to
reveal or identify hidden Properties or
enchantments when cast causes the target
object to reveal any hidden magic or
properties
sponge knees curse this curse makes the
victim's knees weak and sponge-like when
cast it causes the target's knees to
become weak and wobbly making it
difficult for them to stand or move
without support
spongify this charm softens objects
making them bouncy and rubbery squiggle
quill this charm transforms quills used
for writing into worms
stealth censoring spell this spell is
used to detect those under magical
disguise like someone using the
disillusionment charm stenius this dark
charm causes the victim to sneeze for a
short period of time it's often used in
dueling settings to temporarily distract
an opponent
stinging jinx this Jinx stings the Flesh
of a Target the stretching jinx this
Jinx causes the target to elongate or
stretch making it difficult for them to
move and function normally
Stupify also known as the stunning spell
this spell is used to stun or knock out
a Target rendering them unconscious
super sensory charm this charm enhances
the cast as sensors heightening
perceptions and allowing them to see
hear smell and feel things with greater
Clarity and detail sergito this counter
charm is used to remove enchantments
switching spell this charm is used to
swap the positions of two objects or
individuals when cast it causes the
target items or individuals to switch
places often without warning or control
taboo this detection enchantment is used
to identify or track the use of a
specific word or phrase when cast it
alerts the Caster or relevant
authorities when the designated word or
phrase is spoken revealing the location
of the speaker this Jinx was notably
placed on the word Voldemort
tail-growing spell this hex causes the
target to grow a tail tarant Allegra
this charm also known as the dancing
feet spell forces the target's legs to
dance uncontrollably
teacup to tortoise this Transfiguration
spell transforms a teacup into a
tortoise teapot to tortoise same as
above but with a teapot
teeth straightening spell this charm is
used to straighten and align crooked
teeth
teleportation spell this spell vanishes
objects and causes them to reappear
elsewhere Dumbledore uses this spell on
Harry's school supplies clothes and owl
tentacle Force this Jinx transforms the
target's head into a giant tentacle
turgio this charm is used to siphon
liquid and clean objects
titillando this hex causes tickling the
temporarily weakens and distracts a
victim
toenail growing hex this hex causes the
target to experience accelerated toenail
growth which may cause discomfort or
difficulty in walking
transmography and torture this curse is
one of the most horrific in The
Wizarding World allegedly it tortures a
victim to death by grotesquely
contorting their body
and tribunus this spell improves the
quality of food within a location
trip jinx this Jinx causes the target to
trip and fall over
Twitchy ears hex this hex causes the
target's ears to Twitch uncontrollably
unbreakable charm this powerful charm is
used to make an object indestructible
when cast it provides a permanent and
unyielding protection to the Target
object making it impervious to damage or
destruction
unbreakable valve this Bell produces a
binding magical contract between two
individuals when made the person making
the vow makes a promise to fulfill a
specific task or condition and if they
fail to do so they will suffer dire
consequences including possible death
Snape and Narcissa notably engage in the
unbreakable vow
unsupported flight this Bell refers to
the ability to fly through the air
unsupported without the need for a broom
or other flying object
vacuum cleaner spell this charm causes
the Caster's wand to suck up dirt dust
and debris like a vacuum cleaner
Juventus this offensive spell produces
jet of strong spiraling wind from the
tip of the wand Ventus Duo this is a
more powerful version of Ventus creating
an even greater jet of wind
verto this Bell which we see used by
McGonagall turns animals into water
goblets verdilius this charm conjures
green Sparks from the tip of the wand
verdemelius similar to verdilius this
spell conjures green Sparks however
these Sparks are powerful enough to be
used in a dueling environment they can
also be used to reveal things hidden by
dark magic
verdemelius Duo this is the most
advanced version of the verdamilia spell
and produces a more powerful effect
vermilius this Bell countries red Sparks
that can be used to Signal an emergency
Victor rookwood's curse this curse used
on ansalo can cause a victim
considerable pain and illness lasting
many years
vipera aveneska this very specific spell
causes snakes to disappear or vanish
Into Thin Air with no physical remains
or traces left behind
vulnera salentor
the counter spell to sectum sempra this
healing spell slows blood flow clears
residue and emits wounds promoting
faster healing what a wassy this spell
is used to shoot small soft masses of
whatever the Caster desires at the
Target the limitations of this spell are
not well documented
washing up spell this handy charm is
used to enchant dirty dishes forcing
them to clean and wash themselves
Wingardium Leviosa Leviosa not leviosar
this rather famous spell is used to
levitate objects
when cast it allows the cast to make an
object float and move it through the air
it requires proper pronunciation and
technique to achieve the desired
levitation effect as Hermione will
remind us all white Sparks this charm
produces a jet of white Sparks from the
tip of the wand
I thought I'd never be saying this but
that about sums it up 309 spells in
total and I'm sure I've still managed to
miss a few which spells are your
favorite which ones did I miss please do
leave me a comment down below until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
[Music]
foreign